blattmann numero 23 mi ha obbligato lui
a farlo con questa sono ridicolo questo
turbante inserito stiamo andando a
napoli e cielo che mi vuole far vedere
un sacco di cose di napoli attivo
natalizie al suo garante napoli in festa
si faci un perito natalizie pazzesca
qui sappiamo fare festa che una
meraviglia
ok
e andiamo abbiamo dormito una cosa tipo
12 ore di fila è stata una roba
imbarazzante so e mi sono svegliato più
stanco di prima già oggi solo una specie
di butta
guardami
non capisco perché così tanto mento
dette napoli che mi trasforma in totò
leggermente lo so tutti inquadrature
così dall'alto per voi per l'eroe così
allora via
compito come quasimodo luigi va a
prendere una scorciatoia e ci siamo
completamente perso e allora non è vero
ne scuso
su
che appena letto sono persi aiuto aiuto
siamo persi ultimi acquisti di natale
così al volo di odio gli si sta aprendo
pure egli si sta aprendo
ma perché non accostano nono zio
se ti prego fermate si sta aprendo tutto
lo rete colpire riguarda le prove mamma
mia casa che avrebbe mai vista così
sembra quasi che sia la stessa persona
che guida altro che smartwatch comoda
tascabile non facile da vedere però
giusto ma se la sono già le 2 10
chiuso fame
ti prego non c'è qualcosa o fame
ehi siri è il google ei savana qua che
sia ora di amazon alex sa che cosa una
tristezza forze stanno facendo lavori e
lo capisco la per regista regolare dal
treno per firenze può dire pazzi che
a mostrare la merce per natale e per
la befana dei bambini che ne so c'era
l'impossibile potevo sentire
sei perfetto per linea verde
c'erano persone che possiamo vedere le
cose le cose facevano vedere così che
non sono queste cose erano altre cose le
cose che tendevano lasciamo parlare le
immagini contenute
lasciamo parlare le immagini
ma stai parlando ancora tu facciamo
parlare le immagini come natalizio
questo guarda come natalizio lui tavolo
ragazzi quanto la quanto quanto natale o
che carino io da piccolo sognavo questi
qui con tutto il mio cuore
che fico e questa cosa
mando a questi programmi
mando nessuno enormi
sono giganti settimana
questo è il reparto patient e
vegetariani
così musiche musiche che bello che è
bellissimo da come sembra vicina e
peretto sembra vicina mentre scendevo
che bella che guarda che bello
io sto volando
ecco telefono sta morendo
da notare un romanzo anche lui il cos'è
sto coso disabitato ma è tutto tondo e
frecce e ripeto non è a metà
non è una pizza fiera trans se stessa o
kapitza intera
a napoli
questi sono civili versi che cos'è che
sto dicendo lì quasi non si può
il grasso di maiale credo si mette così
sembra che uno schifoso per assimilarne
c'è il punto più vuoto
certo attimo la pancetta ma di quella
ignorantone però va bene ambiti dove
l'appetito
luigi la bravo presentatore di onda
verde ha deciso di leggere la
definizione circoli online in modo da
essere sicuro di non fare brutte figure
sei pronto ok allora deciso di non sono
altresì il residuo della bollitura delle
parti grasse del maiale in un pentolone
c'è la roba che sale su go sì
esattamente
inizialmente liquida si solidifica e non
ce lo sappiamo
in sostanza parte grazie ma in genere si
mangia di sognare appresa
certamente però quanto buona era infatti
era buona
sogna rappresa e la chiami cicoli invece
di nuovo calzone fritto di signa
rappresa la gabella creato
stupendo
geniale no vabbè guarda sono tutti i
presepi
tra dalla di apple i presepi con tutte
le statuine quelle simpatiche avevo
addio
ma questo e per il presepe certo mi
aspetti sui calciatori ci metti il papa
ci va solo sul piano rehn fantozzi
michael maria de filippi maria de
filippi
credo sia laura possibile lei o cattivi
sempre
chi verrà anni
no corone d'argento va beh caro
ci siamo innamorati di queste fontane
e lui vorrebbe fare un regalo a mia
mamma indecisi fra gesù è una fontana
non è questo da gesù è pieno il mondo in
gesù oggi abbiamo pure questo
questi derivati sono bellissimi e quello
che barberino
lui animali e centrerebbe amare juventus
batte stupisce faccia quest'altra
vedendo tutti questi pezzettini del
presepe che ci stava spiegando come ti
chiami sposa fabio fabio fecci ricava
che praticamente vedi anno a seconda del
movimento che deve far tipo la lavandaia
ci mettiamo lo snodo che fa così è
possibile che certe proprio la carta
un'altra cosa ma è bellissimo che poi
vestendoli giustamente non vedi più
niente vestiti per esempio questo sarà
un taglialegna se si farà questo momento
è bellissimo è questo qua è un fornaio e
si vede al movimento anche a bacino si
oppure anche un ballerino di salsa
che bello ed è questo che invece è
l'isola borazione laboratorio dove
mettere insieme quanto lavoratori e ma
che scherzi caos totale quindi all
ordine mentale esatto qualcosa metti la
mano venuti i fratelli sai dove tutti i
pezzi sono tipo leggermente diversi a
modo loro giusto perché esatto quali ma
nel vestiario nel mestiere nella tipo di
forma i beni sono due sono tali
differenti questo per esempio lui è lui
è quello che lavora più di tutti perché
ne ha fatte 6
loro invece ne hanno solamente tre nella
nostra pizza maxi bisogna giusto lazio
la pasta se in questo caso a chiuderla
tipo che vendono in piazza 2 quando
entrati in questo nome siete pregati non
parlare di malattie né tantomeno di
miseria per non piangere chef figo e nel
traditore io non ci capisco niente di
calcio una seduta fa spiegare
volevamo andare a mangiare che cos'è
bravo mangiare la pizza da scaturchio si
chiama scaturchio ci siamo affacciati
c'era sembra non lo so ibiza e ho detto
guarda è stato bellissimo ma non ce la
faccio più
io ho questo problema che devo prendere
a piccole dosi l'umanità un po devo
tornare il mio antro buio di cibo sì
anche se si tratta di cibo
preferisco infilare la faccia nel burro
ripassiamo davanti all'orologio che
adesso segna come orario si è fatta una
certa in cosa si che funziona era giusto
l'orario prima sono io che non
funzionano più
eccole delle dell'illuminazione semplici
quell'orologio il candelabro così cos'è
il semplice quella catena allora
ma lui
chi sta andando alla velocità del suono
con un monopattino brevemente lettere
comunque presa così anche incentivato da
luca ha fatto il regalo a mio padre ha
fatto sta rosa del presepe a mio nonno
nel potere e tu che cosa hai fatto a tua
mamma io ero ancora niente sono stato
molto impegnato
vabbè falli a regalo e amanti che lo
faccio magari non farglielo adesso che
va bene glielo faccio adesso
questo
stavo andando a fare regala mia mamma
lo so lo so non sono quel tipo di bravo
figlio sono bravo per altri motivi non
per questo possa farsi la domanda quale
quali park
bene
chiudiamo bene un sacco gli altri motivi
dai scherzo eh mica ho fatto una moda
manco io la faccio
ora sta a vedere che cosa una rapa un
ragazzo via libera eravamo praticamente
un colloquio da ravera un piccolissimo e
fanno dai quali mi raccomando ragazzi
bisogna impegnarsi poi bisogna fare la
moda lui si alzano
io non lo faccio da sola
miyazaki pietrino
avevamo tre anni 23 neuroni di emma ma
una signora 6 mamma una signora comporre
un regalo pazzesco svenato mi renato
svenarmi svegliare il minimum mamma una
signora 6
ci piace io sono tornati a casa dopo
mangiato con i porci tiri ma presto
tornerà luna ma rotolo non faccio a
piedi sta finendo il flop ma ci siamo
fatti gli auguri con lui e adesso si
torna a roma ci vediamo lì con la strage
del montaggio noi mezzo di pacchi sono
arrivata a casa
sono stanco morto che dire io quasi
quasi da chiudere qua anche perché
domani è un giorno importante l'ultimo
blog mas e io non ci credo di esserci
arrivato sinceramente vivo quindi che
dire mi devo pure svegliare prestissimo
perche devo cucinare dovevo fare ancora
dei pacchi prega li vedo come al solito
sempre all'ultimo vabbè che dire io a
questo punto ora peter qui ci vediamo
domani con l'ultimo blog mans sempre
alle 14 ciao